The Unreal Engine 5 Texture Editor is a powerful tool that allows you to adjust various properties
of your textures once they've been imported into the Engine.
You can quickly access the Texture Editor by double clicking on any texture you see in
the Content Browser or Texture Input you see throughout the Editor.
Let's take a look at the tool in a little more depth by going over to the Editor now.
Once we're in the Editor, I'm going to hit Control Space to bring up my Content Browser.
Then I'm going to go over here to Texture.
Once I do that, I'm going to double click on this Bark Texture and you'll notice as soon
as I do that, I'm brought to the Texture Editor.
The Texture Editor should look kind of similar with the File, Edit, Asset, Window, Tools,
and Help menu across the top as many of the other editors in Unreal Engine 5 have.
Next what we have is our Save and our Browse to Asset.
Remember this Browses to this Asset in the Content Browser.
Then we have Reimport which allows us to reimport this asset from the location it was imported
from.
Then we have the ability to isolate the red, green, blue, or alpha channels of this Texture.
This is useful if you're using a masked workflow and you want to isolate each channel for further
inspection.
Next to that we have the ability to adjust which MIP level is currently being displayed.
This will allow us to further inspect that in case there are issues.
Now for those of you who are unaware, MIP maps are generated for you by default if the
Texture you have imported is a power of two in the X and the Y axis.
We covered this in a few slides in the beginning of this presentation.
Next to that we have the ability to zoom.
This allows us again to just kind of get a closer inspection on our Texture here.
We can also do this by using the middle mouse wheel and scrolling up or down.
Next to that we have our preview platform.
This allows us to adjust the Texture compression settings here to emulate what it would look
like on an Android, iOS, Linux, Mac, TV, or Windows device.
Our Details panel allows us to look at some important information at the top such as the
imported size, displayed size, and max end game size of this Texture.
We can also see the resource size or the amount of memory that this is going to consume.
These numbers up here are important because we can actually constrain our textures to
have a different resolution than what they were originally imported with.
This can help in terms of memory as remember reducing Texture size will help reduce the
amount of resources this will consume.
On the right hand side of that we have a method streamed format DTX, supports format Alpha
false, combined LOD bias zero, number of MIPs 11, and our end code speed final.
Out of these settings the ones that you need to pay most attention to are method streamed,
format, and number of MIPs.
Remember that if we want to use Unreal Engine's advanced Texture Streaming System we need to
make sure that our textures are a power of two in the X and the Y axis and if they are
then this method stream will show up right here and we want to see that as well as the
number of MIP maps.
With that we have our level of detail, compression, texture, adjustment, file pass, and compositing
sections.
Let's take a look at these in detail.
So level of detail what this does is this controls how our MIP maps are generated.
In the MIP GIN settings right here if we click on this drop down we have the ability to either
sharpen or blur.
So if I was to say blur this and let's just do like a blur five and I come here to my
LOD bias which allows us to bias this or change the size of the LOD.
You can see here that that is very very very blurry and that's not really what I want.
So I'm just going to go, actually I'm just going to reset this default so that you can
see what that actual option does right here.
So this is just a little pro tip.
Anytime you set something and you want to get back to what you were before and you don't
know just press this and you will automatically go back to the default.
Another group down here what this allows us to do is set this texture to another group
and we can control these groups through our INIs and the groups allow us to control settings
that we're seeing inside of this texture editor should we want to adjust all of the textures
in our project.
Compression deals with how this is going to be compressed.
Now one thing that we might want to consider enabling is this compressed without alpha.
The reason for this is that alpha textures take up about two times as much memory because
alpha information is uncompressed.
Because of this we want to make sure that any textures we're using do not accidentally
contain alpha information.
So by making sure that compressed without alpha is enabled when we import a texture
the alpha information will be removed even if it was there by accident.
The other setting that we need to be aware of here is our compression settings.
What this allows us to do is adjust the different compression methods that are used on this
texture.
Now most of the time default or normal map which Unreal will set for you will be okay.
But if you happen to be dealing with something like maybe a mask or a vector displacement
or maybe a HDR image that's where you'll want to change these settings right here in order
to accommodate for that compression method.
Under texture we have our padding and resizing and what this will do is this will allow us
to take non-power of two textures and modify them in a way that turns them into a power
of two texture.
And then sRGB right here this makes sure that we enable or disable gamma correction.
This is highly important for dealing with a mask or a normal map we always want to make
sure we have this turned off.
This allows us to adjust various properties of this texture.
So for example if I want to make it a little bit darker I can do something like that.
If I want to make it a little brighter I can do something like that.
The great part is also remember that this is non-destructive even if I was to save this
by adjusting it I could simply come back here and undo that setting and it would go right
back to the way it was before.
Our file path shows us the file and the date stamp of when this was edited and then compositing
deals with compositing when we composite with this.